So we were discussing the 17th most
common question asked by the non-Muslim
regarding how can you prove logically
the existence of hereafter.
I ask a simple question. Now this
question I'm asking
to a non-Muslim
who does not believe in God and does not
believe in the hereafter because the
question asked to me if someone asks me
I'm Muslim if someone asks me the
question that can you logically prove
the existence of hereafter
and I believe the person asking me is
not a Muslim he does not believe in God
he does not believe in hereafter so I
ask him a counter question that is
robbing good or bad? Now if you have to
reply on behalf of the person of the
non-Muslim,
what answer will you give? Is robbing
good or bad?
Bad. Is robbing good or bad?
Bad. Okay. Now I
I Dr. Zakin Knight hypothetically
suppose I am a big mafia. I'm a big
gangster number one in the world. I'm a
big robber. hypothetically. Now I'm
telling to you
that robbing is good. I'm a very logical
person. I'm a very scientific person. I
can give you number of reasons why
robbing is good. When I rob and I
$1,000, I can go and eat in a fivestar
hotel.
When I rob $100,000, I can buy a good
watch, Rolex watch.
If I rob half a million dollar, I can
buy a Rolls-Royce.
If I rob a million dollar, I can buy a
big villa in Mombasa next to the sea.
Correct? It's good.
I am a logical person. I am a scientific
person. Give me only one, not two, not
three. One reason why robbing is bad and
I will stop robbing.
One reason why robbing is bad.
I give you so many reasons if I rob I
can buy a watch. I can eat fivestar
hotel. I can buy a car, Rolls-Royce. I
can buy a big villa. Right or wrong,
IT'S GOOD. I'M ENJOYING LIFE. Give me
one good reason why robbing is bad. Yes,
sister. Why is robbing bad? So many
sisters said it is bad. Why it is bad?
Try.
Sorry,
I can't hear you.
So haram
why you are a non-Muslim doesn't believe
in God what is haram for you? You are
giving the answer on behalf
of a non-Muslim who's posing in the
question to prove the existence of
hereafter.
So can you give me one logical reason
why robbing is bad? Yes brother give it
a try. Why it is bad? Sorry,
somebody will kill me. Brother, I have
got many bodyguards all hiding behind
the stage. I told you I'm a big mafia.
You didn't hear my question. I have 100
bodyguards. Before you kill me, they'll
kill you.
If it's a small robot is bad for him
because he may not have bodyguards. I'm
big mafia. All hiding behind the shade.
All hiding behind the stage. You know,
behind the screen there are 100
bodyguards with AK AK 47.
Small robber. It's not good for I'm a
big robber, big mafia, number one in the
world. No one can kill me. I can kill
them. Try out. Why robing is bad?
Yes, brother.
Sorry.
No peace.
>> Sorry.
>> You creates problem. I create
>> problems. Nobody
>> problem. Very good. Very good. He says
I'M CREATING PROBLEM. THE PERSON WHO I
ROBBED poor man will suffer. Correct.
But what different miss to me I told you
prove me why it is wrong for me not for
that when I rob I agree with you problem
for that man but for me luxury I'm buy
Rolex watch I'm buying Rolls-Roy I'm
buying villa what problem for me I told
you give me one logical reason why it is
bad for me I do agree it is bad for the
person who I have robbed I'm not
disagreeing I'm a logical man correct I
told you to give me One logical reason
why it is bad for me.
Yes, brother.
You didn't want it happening to you.
Sorry. You not want that to happen to
you. You didn't want to be robbed
yourself. No one can rob me. Brother is
saying somebody will rob me. No one can
rob me because I'm a mafia. I'm number
one. The small robber. Yes, I agree with
you. A small robber, a big robber can
rob him. I'm the biggest number one. So
your logic is correct for small robers.
Those who are the small thief don't rob
somebody will rob you. For me I'm number
one. No one dare come close to me. I
have got bodyguards. I'm number one in
the world. Tell me why it is wrong for
me and I stop robbing only one. I don't
want two. I don't want three. Give me
one logical reason why robbing is wrong.
It's bad. I stop it. Yes sister.
Sorry,
I can't hear you.
Can someone repeat what she's saying?
Yes, sister. What did you say? Can we
have one more microphone for the gents?
>> Salam.
You're a non-Muslim saying no.
>> You develop kibri.
>> Sorry.
Kibri.
>> Kibri.
>> Kibri. Yes.
What is she saying? Can you understand?
>> She said you are developing ego.
>> You are developing ego. What's wrong
with ego? No problem.
Who says ego is wrong? I am a logical
person. I'm a scientific person. Ego,
ego is good for me. I'm getting free
food, fivestar food, good watches, good
cars, good What is wrong? What is wrong
in ego? Is it causing me any problem
scientifically? Can you prove to me what
is wrong?